I will import numpy.
as MP and
Matlab and
math
plot limit
so we can see what principal components are and then
we can visualize them.
now
what I'm going to show you is a matrix.
There is two by six.
So it has two columns and six six rows. This
is a very simple Matrix and it's just and it's
small enough so that we can
You know get the get the point of PCA and then of course.
In the next example, we will look at
a large.
Data set. So this one only has two dimensions.
Ultimately, what we want to do is we want to project this two-dimensional.
Data onto one. I want dimensional into
one dimension. So we want to go from
essentially two vectors to one vector. Let me explain what
I mean.
So we are going to perform SVD on this.
Okay, and remember we said that PC is a special
case of SVD now we're not going to do this. We're not
going to use grab Schmidt and normalization. We're
just going to use a built-in method of
numpy called SVD. So there's a method
called NP.
It's a SVD in the object linear algebra.
And it's returned value will be 3.
Things and we'll start well, it will be two matrices
and one vector.
But you will assign to you.
As and V.
So the return value of this method will be a matrix Vector Matrix
respectively.
And after all and that's this SVD composition and
then I'll print all three.
Variables I'll print you.
And us and V.
So this is the Matrix U.
the eigenvalues
that will be put in the
Matrix
SS for Sigma, okay.
In a PCA the S is a sigma use the
Greek letter.
and
The Matrix V
All right.
The next thing we are going to do is I'm going
to put these eigenvalues.
in an identity Matrix
So again, you see here. This is an identity Matrix.
But instead of once we have the argumentality, so I'm
going to produce this Square Matrix.
and to do this
first
I will assign.
lowercase s to uppercase s because the
convention you know, we want to follow linear algebra
convention where
a we use the we use a lowercase letters
to denote the vectors uppercase that is to denote
matrices.
So I'm going to change uppercase as to small
as
uppercase test instead will be a matrix.
If you see this is initial on form.
We have ones across the principal diagonal.
we need this to be a six by two because
of the Matrix operation that we're about to perform.
But this is the first eigenvalue.
Second of a second value or if you like the first
singular value in the second singular Valley. Also if
you like the first principle component.
And the second principle component.
Once I start visualizing you will see how this how we're
able to.
Reduce the dimensionality of our data. Now. How
many imagine this were an Excel sheet. We have two columns
of data.
What we're about to do this example is collapsing into one column.
So we go from a two-dimensional letter to one dimensional Theta that's
a lead. That's the linear transformation to go
from R2 to R.
R 1
Now I also want to do this. I want to plot this
Vector on its own axis.
plot this
on its own axis. So this will be let's see X
and this will be y
so
Here, we will say performing SVD.
principal component
SVD
first we need to decompose The Matrix into three matrices.
Then we are going to visualize.
the
column vectors
of a
just so we can have a
intuitive
understanding
No, I'm good to use a technique called the list comprehension. So
if you do not if you haven't seen this before or you
don't remember it.
let me show you I'm gonna go a
That's the Matrix and I'm going to use a square bracket. Of
course.
If you plug in a number.
And these are the indices the index the every index
will correspond to a particular role of a matrix
if I type in zero.
This will be the first row of the original Matrix.
And of course, we remember that we count from 0 and in programming.
if I want the last row I go I go 5
now if I want all of the rows
What this colon means is that.
What precedes the color is the starting range? And what
comes after is this ending range if I type this if I
leave?
Both sides of the colon empty. That means give me all of
the rows.
So here we can see.
The first row is negative 3 negative 3.
The second was negative 2 negative 1. So if I just want the first
two rows I can go 0 1
Or rather zero to that. It has
to be stopping index. There we go.
Now what I actually want.
Is all of the rows.
But I want to only extract the first column.
So I'm going to call this C1.
and it will be negative 3 negative 2 1 negative 1 2 3
So what I'm going to say, I want all of the rows all of
the rows.
from the first column
and that will give me
these components
Animal, I'll also do it for the second column.
So all of the rows from the second column again, we count from
0.
Which is why this is one.
now I'm going to
plot these
two vectors. So C1 and C2 are both now vectors.
Okay, however, I'm going to treat these as
points on the x-axis.
And for C2 it will be points on the y-axis. Basically. We're
just draw two.
one horizontal and one
vertical column
and I'll see what and I'll show you why we want to do this.
So to plot I'm going to use the PLT method PLT Dot.
scatter
so I want so you want to be on the x-axis. I'm
going to type in C1.
for the y-axis
we want
I'm gonna set it to zero.
Okay, six elements corresponding with
the six points in that vector.
And then I should have will see as plts.
Yeah, thank you, Ron. I fixed up.
Now I also want to color code these points.
So this will be zero negative 3, excuse me,
negative 3 0 negative 2 0
Once you see there's a points right? These are the points
corresponding to the x-axis. These are the points corresponding on the
y-axis.
I want to color code these I want to color code the X points
that are
the left of the origin
Beside it. Basically the numbers that are negative will have one
color the numbers that are positive will have another color.
So I'm going to say c c is the parameter for
color.
And the criteria for shooting the color.
is
C1 greater than 0
so if the components see what are above
we will get one color if they are below zero will get another color.
and we will let me just set the
the no never mind.
It's Gonna Change Dimensions, let me see what this looks like.
Okay. There we go.
and I'll do the same for the second column
of Matrix a
maybe what I should have done is typed and make this a1a2.
Make it clear.
Let me run this again.
and then a two
let's change the order of these arguments.
So the idea is this.
We have two dimensions of data.
these two vectors
and what we want to do is retain this
spread.
this variation
but in one axis in one vector
So I'm going to retained this value.
these
this spread in one diagonal
So here this is one dimension of our data.
the second dimension of our data
however, we want to do is use the
principal components
Which are the Eugene values?
To collapse this into one axis without
while keeping.
This spread as much as possible.
So here's what I'll do next.
I am going to take
the first principle component
multiplied by
the first principle Direction
we open this again.
now you
I know it has it's it's quite
Maybe Missy but the First Column Vector
in U is the first principle Direction.
What I'm going to do is I'm going to multiply.
the first principle component by the
principal direction of the Matrix U
Now the principal component is also.
the first principle component
Is the component that has the largest values if
I come back here?
If we look at this example, this was a completely different Matrix.
The largest singular value or large eigenvalue. This
Matrix is the number 14.
This number also corresponds in the
context of PCA.
to the
variants in the data
so the first eigenvalue
Is the first principle component and it's also the
represents the largest variance
in the data?
Now another step why we need to keep the variance of the data. We'll
have to look at a second example.
so first
We will focus on visualizing understanding dimensionality
reduction.
And the later on we'll look another example where we have a larger
data set.
And a core variance Matrix is involved this example since it's
only two columns is too small.
Okay.
so let's
See the principle. Excuse me.
Let's see the
dimensionality reduction first and then we'll
talk about covaries and correlation matrices.
Okay.
in order to visualize our first
principle component we will take
s if you remember s was
the okay. I did not run the celebration.
No, I have to run it from the top.
on all
yeah, so
is the eigenvector?
And this is the largest principle component which will
be the first principal component.
So in order to get the first principle compound, we will use index 0
We will then multiply this by.
The First Column of the Matrix U. So
again if we return to here to this
writing
If this is the Matrix U we're going to multiply this.
principle component by the first principle Direction
So I'm going to multiply this by U.
I want all of the rows.
from
the first column
if I run this
I now have a linear transformation.
we've gone from Matrix to
a vector
So this is the vector corresponding to
the first principle component.
I plot this now if I go PLT.
I have to code here by the way.
plot
principal component
one
So I'm going to pass this twice.
And let's just call this pc14 by the way.
PC one
so the points on the both X and Y axis
will be PC one.
It's a line that will go through the origin.
And it will be linear.
Where peace you want the components and pc1 are greater
than zero.
I'm setting the X and Y limits to negative 5 to 5 for
both the X and Y axis because well the components of
the principal components.
Grow from negative 4 to positive 4 so we
just want to make room two so we can see it.
This is the result.
of PCA
we have taken those two dimensions.
Which you can see we're quite spread.
And we have combined both dimensions.
We have combined both vectors into one vector.
while keeping the variance while retaining
a significant amount of the data
if we do the same thing for the second principle component.
You will see that it retains data, but not
as much as the first one.
This is amazing because
if there was any correlation if there's any significance any
significant relationship between the two first
columns
Well now the r let's say merged or
combined into one.
into one
Dimension so we've gone from two Dimensions to one dimension.
This will become incredibly powerful, especially when we have a larger
data sets.
We go, for example, 20 Dimensions or 15
Dimensions down to one or two
or three principal components making the job of a machine learning model.
a lot easier
now there's more to our discussions. So we haven't even gotten into
discussion of
The covariance Matrix yet
But we'll do that. Let's actually leave this here.
For later reference. Hopefully you've understood what we mean by
dimensionality reduction.